a little meditation plenty of my ties
bruce banner's recovery during the blip
was nothing short of incredible marvel
studios phase 4 slate has focused on new
characters and new worlds in the marvel
cinematic universe for the current era
of the franchise officially titled the
multiverse saga and the she-hulk series
adds jennifer walters to the roster in
the comics she's a high-flying lawyer
who gets a blood transfusion from her
cousin bruce banner after she gets shot
by mobsters in savage she-hulk number
one but the gamma radiation in his blood
transforms jen into she-hulk who could
have seen that coming thankfully the
series takes a different approach to
jyn's origin
as bruce's blood spills into her wound
when the cousins get involved in a car
accident in the first episode of
she-hulk this makes sense because banner
would know about the dangers of
purposefully giving his cousin a blood
transfusion considering his own unique
condition the show also pulls from john
burns the sensational she-hulk comics
which see the hero break the fourth wall
to talk to the reader head writer
jessica gao told the hollywood reporter
that she originally wanted to use that
format in an even bigger way in the
series she said
it was tricky finding the balance
because if i had my way she'd be
breaking the fourth wall every other
sentence everybody had to pull me back a
little bit more from it jennifer
breaking the fourth wall injects the
series with a sense of fun especially
opposite ruffalo's professor hulk who
teaches his cousin how to handle her
newfound abilities
so if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer i respect that
thanks he doesn't mean that
but while jyn and bruce catch up the
scientist reveals what the hulk did
during the blip after thanos erased half
of all life in the universe the world
drastically changed in the five years
between avengers infinity war and
avengers end game due to half the
population disappearing as a result of
the snap but when fans see hulk again in
end game bruce banner has figured out a
way to combine his alter ego's strength
and size next to his own intellect and
personality it's a surprising
development for the scientist but it's
one that allows him to still be part of
the action while also pushing his
character arc further but she-hulk
episode 1 reveals that it wasn't an easy
feat to pull off bruce tells jennifer
that he spent much of his time alone in
his remote mexican laboratory which was
funded by tony stark
but this is where i spent a blip fixing
myself and integrating the hulk banner
identities bruce created a device there
to help him control his two sides
putting the brains and the brawn
together this lab would also be where
bruce healed his arm after the events of
endgame as he was fairly injured from
using the stark gauntlet it's great that
banner spent his time productively
during the blip but it's hard not to
think that he could have been doing more
out in the world bruce could have helped
natasha romanov try and keep the world
from falling apart with the remaining
avengers during the blip she's not doing
so great at the start of avengers
in-game because of everything she's been
through and bruce could have been there
for her
after all once upon a time the two were
very close in age of ultron in the first
act of avengers end game most of the
surviving heroes work together during
the fallout nebula rocket okoye captain
marvel and war machine are all doing
their part across earth and the universe
the fact that bruce hid out in mexico
trying to work on his new smart hulk ego
and not helping his friends is quite
unusual regardless of his absence during
the blip it's safe to say that if
professor hulk had not come to be
jessica walter's transition into
she-hulk would have been much harder to
handle or might not have even happened
at all
[Music]